[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute möchte ich endlich eine
einschulungsrate machen und zwar habe
ich mich dazu entschlossen eine
schultüte zu backen
weil sich die einfach so viele von euch
gewünscht hatten aber natürlich kann man
auch eine einstellungsquote ganz anders
gestalten indem er zum beispiel nur
einer runde torte packt und dann einfach
so ein paar schuhe gegenstände aus von
dann modelliert ich habe das jetzt so
gemacht dass ich eine nuss kuren gemacht
habe aber ihr könnt natürlich auch jeden
anderen kuchen nehmen
am besten macht ihr ein rezept mit einer
26 cm form und dieses rezept habe ich
dann genommen und in einigen backform
gebacken also wenn sie ein rezept zum
beispiel euren lieblings schokokuchen
dann rechnet ihr den auf die 26 cm form
um in der umrechnung tabelle gibt es ja
auf meinem blog die kann ich euch dann
auch nochmal verlinken
und dann könnt ihr jeden kuchen da rein
backen also auch die zitronen torte
schokotorte alles mögliche und ich würde
jetzt einfach mal sagen ich zeige euch
wie ich den biskuit teig herstellen das
zeige ich euch natürlich auch noch ganz
wichtige tipps wie der bis geteilt
richtig gut gelingt und dann kommt da
eine leckere schoko buttercreme rhein
und die ist wirklich super lecker
also jetzt geht es mit dem rezept für
den teig brauchen wir sieben eier 240
gramm zucker eine prise salz 45 gramm
kakaopulver 80 gramm speisestärke 75
gramm haselnüsse ich habe jetzt ganz
haselnüsse werde sie auch gleich rösten
und dann malen
ihr könnt aber auch gleich geriebene
haselnüsse nehmen aber so ist einfach
roma viel intensiver und schmeckt viel
frischer einen halben teelöffel
backpulver einen halben teelöffel zimt
140 gramm mehl und 50 gramm flüssige
butter dies jetzt schon abgekühlt und
hier habe ich die eier auch auf
zimmertemperatur übrigens verwende ich
immer ganz gern diesem esslöffel zum
abmessen also hier habe ich einen
esslöffel einen teelöffel einen halben
teelöffel und ein viertel teelöffel so
habt ihr nämlich immer exakt die gleiche
menge egal von welchem hersteller euro
es läuft nämlich sind kann es nämlich
passieren dass er einfach ungenau messen
und so habt ihr immer einheitlich eine
richtige menge
zuerst werde ich jetzt einmal die
haselnüsse rösten denn so bekommen sie
ein richtig tolles aroma das mache ich
einfach ganz trocken in der pfanne bis
es anfängt zu rauchen
die haselnüsse könnt ihr dann einfach in
einem mixer geben
bei manchen könnt ihr auch noch die
schale etwas ableiten und dann einfach
ganz fein mahlen ihr könnt aber auch
gerne ein paar stückchen drin lassen
[Musik]
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die eier gemeinsam
mit dem zucker und dem salz in einer
rührschüssel und lasst sie richtig
schaumig schlagen
das dauert bei mir jetzt etwa 15 bis 20
minuten
so sieht jetzt aus wie ihr sehen könnt
tochter nichts mal runter er ist
ziemlich fest es läuft nicht mehr
und jetzt werde ich das mehl und die
anderen passenden zutaten und erhebt
[Musik]
und dem jetzt einfach einen teig sauber
und tipps von außen nach innen unter
[Musik]
sind pulver dürft ihr natürlich auch
nicht vergessen die gehackten und
geriebenen haselnüsse mit dazu und da
merkte dann auch wie toll die riechen
wenn sie wirklich gerüstet werden vor
allem und da gebe ich auch gleich die
butter noch mit dazu
ich habe jetzt hier bereits meinen back
rahmen vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
ihnen hier an der kurzen seite ganz
zusammengeschoben und hier die lange
seite komplett ausgenutzt und der rahmen
ist jetzt auf etwa 22 x 36 cm
eingestellt und da fühle ich jetzt den
tag hinein
[Musik]
und dann wird er sofort im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad für etwa 25 bis 30
minuten gebacken
ihr seht jetzt auch hier am rand läuft
jetzt ganz leichter teig raus und
deswegen muss man ja auch sofort packen
denn je länger als datei hier steht umso
schneller läuft es aus der backform
heraus und der teig ist fertig wenn bei
der stäbchen probe nix mehr hängen
bleibt ich lasse ihn jetzt ganz kurz
abkühlen und bei denen gleich aus der
vor stürzen
ich werde übrigens ab und zu gefragt wie
ich diese parole damit der sauber kriege
ich nehme einfach eine teig karte und
ziehe dann diesen übrigen teig weg und
spüle das dann einfach mit etwas
spülmittel und meine mission schwamm ab
und lass es dann einfach trocknen
[Musik]
für den pudding brauchen wir 500
milliliter milch
[Musik]
100 gramm zucker ein eigens eine prise
salz eine prise vanilleschote also so
ein bisschen abrieb und vanilleschoten
45 gramm speisestärke und danach
brauchen wir noch 100 gramm peter
kuvertüre die habe ich jetzt schon klein
gehabt 300 gramm weiche butter
und normalerweise nimmt man auch 50
gramm puderzucker
diesen werde ich jetzt allerdings
weglassen weil ich meine torte hat
danach mit front- und einkleiden werde
aber normalerweise nimmt man bei dieser
schoko buttercreme auch diesen zucker
aber wie gesagt den stelle ich jetzt weg
jetzt nehme ich mir für den pudding
diese fünf zutaten und geht's dir
einfach in den topf 18 26 weil wir sind
zwar auf einen blick also einfach alles
in den topf geben nacheinander verrühren
und dann einfach erhitzen
und dann irgendwann kriegt putting 1
also wenn er einmal aufgekocht ist ist
das schon eingedeckt
dann werde ich gleich die hitze
ausschalten dann denke ich das ganze
direkt über dem putting up so dass sich
keine haut bildet und so darf der
pudding einfach hier im zimmer stehen
bleiben und abkühlen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier bereits die
schokolade haben aufgelöst also die
kuvertüre im wasserbad und kann sie
jetzt hier herausnehmen und werde jetzt
die butter in einer küchenmaschine schön
schaumig rühren
jetzt werde ich die butter etwa 345
minuten lang rühren und hull city butter
mit puderzucker macht könnt ihr den
puderzucker an dieser stelle einrühren
während die mutter jetzt verrührt wird
werde ich schon mal den pudding durch
ein sieb streichen damit einfach keine
klümpchen drin vorkommen und gibt dann
den pudding esslöffel weise zur
buttercreme dazu
[Musik]
anschließend gebe ich auch die
geschmolzene und etwas abgekühlte
kuvertüre hinein und lass es fertig
rühren und jetzt probiert sie mal für
kleiner panda bear sag uns mal wie die
schokocreme schmeckt
[Musik]
und die krähen stellt sich jetzt ganz
kurz in den kühlschrank und werk schon
mal den teig mein tag ist jetzt genau 21
cm breit und ich mag ihre mir jetzt
einfach die hälfte also bei 10 5 und bei
der höhe von 20 zentimetern und
schneidet den teig einfach mal dreieckig
aus also diagonal bis in die spitze
unten so dass eben eine schultüte
entsteht die teile schmeiße ich nicht
weg sondern benutzte sie um die torte
eben höher zu gestalten und den 3d
effekt zu bekommen
ich wollte oben den rand wegschneiden
lassen jetzt aber doch dran weil ich
einfach diese kuppel dieser runde noch
mitnehmen möchte dafür nehme ich mir
einfach eine schablone da könnte auch
einen teller benutzen und einfach ins
herum wegschneiden und alle teile
benutzen wir gleich wieder um sie daran
zu setzen und die torte auch richtig
schön
neben 3d mäßig zu gestalten mit der
buttercreme könnt ihr dann die teile
zusammen kleben und einfach auseinander
setzen und dann benutze ich immer wieder
detail kräfte und klebt sie einfach dran
bis sich die richtige form habe die
buttercreme benutze ich hierbei immer
wieder als kleber und als stabilisator
eben
wird immer wieder etwas wegschneiden und
so könnt ihr euch einfach aus eurem
kuchen aus dem kuchenteig diese form
schnitten die ihr braucht die ränder
nehme ich einfach mit einem großen
messer weg und kann so die rundungen
richtig schön gestalten so dass die
torte nicht eckig wird sondern schön rot
wird das mache ich auf beiden seiten und
streicht dann die torte rundherum mit
dieser buttercreme 1
das geht gut mit einem messer aber noch
besser geht es eben mit seiner winkel
palette oder einer normalen streich
palette die buttercreme lässt sich
richtig gut verstreichen weil sie noch
schön weich und geschmeidig ist und ich
habe anschließend auch noch nach dieser
ersten portionen den kuchen kühl
gestellt und noch mal eine zweite
schicht oben drauf gegeben einfach damit
ich alles schön glatt streichen konnte
unten habe ich jetzt doch noch die
spitze weggenommen damit eben die tüte
etwas spitzer wird und eben viel echter
aussieht und und das ganze dann gekühlt
und in der zeit habe ich schon mal die
deko vorbereitet
für die deko habe ich einfach etwas von
uns genommen mit etwas lebensmittel
passten eingefärbt und 10c pulver dazu
gegeben einfach dass ich eine
modelliermasse herstellen konnte und
daraus wollte ich jetzt diese eule
herstellen
ihr könnt natürlich alle motive
herstellen ihr braucht einfach eine
vorlage
ich habs jetzt ohne vorlage gemacht habe
mir einfach ein bild aus dem internet
mal angeschaut das hat mir gut gefallen
habe das ganze dann schon ausgerollt mit
dem hab das ganze schon ausgerollt mit
der fas becker stärke und hab dann diese
iphone benutzt um einfach die eulen form
herzustellen
anschließend habe ich mit einem runden
ausstecher einfach oben ausgesprochen
damit eben die eula diese ohren bekommen
hat und ich hab jetzt mit ganz einfachem
werkzeug gearbeitet also einfach immer
wieder runde kreis ausstecher oder
einfach spritzten genommen und diese
dann immer wieder wird zucker gebe
einfach drum herum geklebt und so könnt
ihr die ganzen einzelteile gestalten
hier habe ich noch die flügel machen
wollen
zuerst habe ich sie mit dem runden aus
schlechter gemacht da waren sie mir zu
klein
dann habe ich doch wieder die eiform
genommen und habe damit dann einfach die
eulen flügel hergestellt und
ausgestochen und die dann dahin geklärt
[Musik]
die farbe habe ich übrigens aus pink und
aus dem lila gemischt
und für die augen habe ich dann immer
wieder die gleichen farbtöne genommen
einfach immer single price ineinander
so habt ihr dann viel mehr details und
hier meldet heißt ihr habt umso toller
sie die torten und auch später aus
[Musik]
bei den augen könnt ihr ganz viel
spielen wenn ihr zb die pupillen in die
mitte setzt sieht das ganze etwas süßes
aus und verspielte aus die eule schild
dann ein bisschen ihr könnt sie aber
auch vertreten nach außen setzen also so
wie ihr es gerne haben wollte mit etwas
orange habe ich dann noch die nase
dreieckig ausgeschnitten und einfach
auch drauf geklebt
[Musik]
aus etwas schwarzen modelle von land
habe ich dann noch die wimpern
ausgeschnitten einfach mit so einem
schönen cut out es geht auch mit einem
ganz scharfen zu einem messer und habe
die dann als wimpernkranz um die augen
gelegt
ich hab leider vergessen der eule noch
füße zu geben
aber das ist dann glaube ich den schluss
nicht aufgefallen aber das hätte ich
auch noch gemacht
mittlerweile habe ich dann noch die
einzelnen federn drauf gestanzt also
eingestanzt kann man auch ganz gut mit
einem strohhalm machen einfach mit
diesem röhrchen ihr könnt aber auch eine
gabel nehmen und einfache motive 1
standen immer ein teures also man
braucht nicht immer ein komplettes
werkzeug sortiment man kann sich auch an
einfachen sachen bedienen
die eule covert antrocknen lassen und
derzeit schon mal den vom land
vorbereiten ich werde die torte mit
weißem von dann überziehen lässt ihn
ganz dünn ausrollen und drauflegen und
einfach schön an den seiten glatt
streichen
das geht auch super bei dieser verbundes
ist auch sehr einfach
die ränder nehme ich dann einfach weg
und streicht die torte mit einem
trockenen blättern einfach platt dann
nochmals sauber wegschneiden mit dem
cutter und oben auch den rand schön
sauber gerade abschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich wieder pinkfarbenen von
hand genommen denen dann oben zum
verschließen der tüte ihr könnt ihr
jetzt schon wellenförmig anlegen und die
tüte so oder so aussehen als hätte man
sie oben zugebunden
[Musik]
mit meinem modell werkzeug habe ich dann
noch ein bisschen struktur hinein
gegeben
[Musik]
habe unten die spitze noch schön mit der
gleichen farbe dekoriert und da kann man
auch viele einzelteile noch reinmachen
mit anderen farben man könnte jetzt
nicht herzchen ausstechen und die darauf
kleben
also da hat man wirklich ganz viel
freiheit mit vielen farben arbeiten
regenbogenfarben
da hat man wirklich jede freiheit und
auch hier immer wieder die ränder schön
sauber abschneiden
zum schluss habe ich noch die eule
darauf platziert und habe eine schöne
schleife drum herum gefunden das mache
ich einfach mit so ein bisschen
geschenkpapier schleife das passt finde
ich am besten weil man das auch so schön
locken kann
natürlich darf der name des kindes auch
nicht fehlen das muss auch immer ganz
groß auf der torte mit drauf sein
da habe ich jetzt amira genommen weil
ich einfach ist auch kein kind hatte
welches eingeschult wird und torte
wollte ich einfach meinen eltern geben
und es soll er einfach nur beispielhaft
sein
jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar stifte
modellieren denn ich finde zu einer
schultüte gehören auch stifte und
geniale und eine tafel und die habe ich
einfach mit dem lineal gerade
abgeschnitten
auf etwa 5 cm länge und 5 mm breite
[Musik]
und dann mit dem lineal einfach längst
zwei streifen eingestanzt und oben und
unten etwas weg geschnitten so dass
etwas von 3d effekt erzielt
mit etwas beigefarbener modelliermasse
dann dieses holzstück noch gestalten und
oben natürlich noch eine schöne farbige
spitze hatte einfach rechts und links
etwas keilförmig einschneiden und
zusammenkleben
[Musik]
für die tafel habe ich einfach die
modelliermasse etwas dunkel grün
eingefärbt mit grün und schwarz und habe
sie dann rechteckig ausgeschnitten und
dann mit etwas beigefarbener
modelliermasse wo ich etwas frauen
eingeknickt habe und habe das so ein
bisschen marmoriert geknetet also nicht
komplett ein geknetet und habt ihr
diesen marmor effekt einfach noch die
streifen abschneiden und den rand der
tafel gestalten
da könnte die einfach vorne etwas
diagonal abschneiden und dran kleben
dann habt ihr einen richtig schönen
effekt und es sieht auch schön sauber
aus da könnt ihr einfach immer wieder
die ränder daran legen und direkt vor
ort dann eben an der tafel wegschneiden
jetzt habe ich natürlich noch einen
stift genommen und habe damit dann die
struktur von holz noch eingezeichnet den
top brand habe ich jetzt einfach mit
etwas dicker zucker noch verschönert den
kann man jetzt natürlich auch noch mit
perlen oder sogar so schmidt
und dann kann man einfach die ganzen
tafeln und stifte darauf anrichten
ich habe jetzt noch blüten passte ganz
dünn ausgerollt und habe etwas auf die
tafel geschrieben so zu sagen habe dann
natürlich einfach die buchstaben
ausgesprochen und auch drauf geht
[Musik]
da könnte man jetzt natürlich noch
lineale gestalten oder ein mädchen oder
noch süßigkeiten mit drauf geben also da
könnt ihr einfach alles machen was euch
eben sehr gut gefällt
die rückstände von der bäcker starke
kann man immer gut mit einem trockenen
pinsel einfach etwas wegputzen und weg
bürsten das klappt dann super und so
habe ich jetzt meine torte angerichtet
habe noch ein abc ausgestochen und hab
das ganze ist reserviert
bevor ich euch jetzt die fertige karte
zeigt zeige ich euch erstmal das was die
samira gemacht hat und zwar war das
glaub ich ein drachen samira war das ein
drachen baby ja ein drachen baby ihr
seht die kleine wird auch mal eine tolle
künstlerin und meine fertige torte sieht
jetzt so aus
normalerweise setzt sich meine torten
immer gern auf capa platten und
überzieht die auch mit fondant aber ich
hatte keine körper platte mit da und
ihnen drei stunden geht unser flieger in
den urlaub und deswegen hatte ich da
jetzt auch keine zeit mehr um die torte
umzusetzen
und ich habe es jetzt nur als beispiel
gemacht als ich verschenke jetzt auch
nicht sondern gibt es ja einfach meinen
eltern mit die dürften die jetzt gleich
zu hause essen
und ja das war jetzt ein gestaltungs
beispiel natürlich könnt ihr auch viele
mehr machen
es gibt auch supertolle ausstecher mit
denen man arbeiten kann und ihr könnt
euch eigentlich jedes bild aus dem
internet zum beispiel von der räume oder
von einem anderen tier als schablone
nehmen und so daneben hier vorne ein
tier oder ein anderes objekt eben
platzieren ich habe zeit eine eule
genommen weil sanierers in euren fan ist
und weil ich ihn einfach total schön
findet ihr ganzes zimmer ist von der
eulen das zeige ich euch mal
und ja das war jetzt mein video und mein
rezept ich hoffe natürlich dass es euch
gefällt wie gesagt das rezept gibt es
dann auf meinem blog sehr starken
welt.de
ich freue mich auf eure kommentare und
bewertungen mein papa zentraler
flüsterte ich nämlich aber ich höre ihn
und ich freue mich natürlich auch wenn
ihr das nächste mal wieder einschaltet
bis dann